I have to ask you
um can you summarize your argument
against the hypothesis that we live in a
simulation
is it similar to our discussion about uh
the Doomsday Clock
um no it's actually pretty more similar
to my
um agnosticism about life in the
universe and it's just sort of remaining
agnostic about all possibilities
um the simulation argument
sometimes it gets
um
mix there's kind of two distinct things
that we need to consider one is the
probability that we live in so-called
base reality that we're not living in a
simulated reality itself and another
probability to consider is the
probability that that technology is
viable possible and something we will
ultimately choose to one day do and
those are two distinct things they're
probably quite similar numbers to each
other but they are distinct
probabilities so my in my paper I I
wrote about this I just tried to work
through the problem I teach astral
statistics actually teaching it this
morning
and so it just seemed like a fun case
study of working through a Bayesian
calculation Fred
um Bayesian calculations work on
conditionals and so when you hear you
know what kind of inspired this project
was when I heard musk said was like a
billion to one chance that we don't live
in a simulation
um
he's right if you add the Bayesian
conditional and the basic additional is
a conditioned upon the fact that we
eventually develop that technology and
choose to use it or it's it's chosen to
be used by such species both
civilizations that's the conditional and
you have to add that in because that
conditional isn't guaranteed
and so um in a Bayesian framework you
can kind of Make That explicit you see
mathematically explicitly that's a
condition on your equation and the the
opposite side of the coin is basically
um in the trilemma that Bostrom
originally put forward it's options one
and two it's option one is that you
basically never developed the ability to
do that option two is you never choose
to execute that so we kind of group
those together as sort of the uh the
non-simulation uh scenario let's call it
and so you've got non-simulation
scenario and simulation scenario and
agnostically we really have to give
though you know how do you assess the
model the April and model probability of
those two scenarios
um it's very difficult and we can I
think people would probably argue about
how you assign those prayers in the
paper we just assigned 50 50. we just
said we this hasn't been demonstrated
yet there's no evidence that this is
actually technically possible but nor is
that it's not technically possible so
we're just going to assign 50 50
probability these two hypotheses and
then in the hypothesis where you have a
simulated reality you have a base
reality cell at the top so there is even
in the simulated hypothesis there's a
probability you still live in base
reality and then there's a whole Myriad
of universes beneath that which are all
simulated and so you have a very you
have a very slim probability of being in
base reality if this is true and you
have a 100 probability of living base
reality on the other hand if it's not
true and we never develop that ability
or choose never to use it and so then
you apply this technique called bazing
averaging which is where you propagate
the uncertainty of your two models to
get a final estimate and because of that
one base reality that lives in the
simulated scenario you end up counting
this up and getting that it always has
to be less than 50 so the probability
living in in a simulated reality versus
base reality has to be slightly less
than 50 percent
um now that really comes down to that
statement of giving it 50 50 odds to
begin with
and on the one hand you might say look
David I'm you know I work in artificial
church I'm very confident that this is
going to happen just of extrapolating of
current trends or on the other hand a
statistician would say you're giving way
too much weight to the simulation
hypothesis because it's an intrinsically
highly complicated model you have a
whole hierarchy of realities within
realities within realities it's like the
Inception style thing right and so this
requires hundreds thousands millions of
parameterizations to describe and by
Occam's razor we would always normally
penalize inherently complicated models
as being disfavored so I think you could
argue on being too generous or too kind
with that but I sort of want to develop
the the rigorous mathematical tools to
explore it and ultimately it's up to you
to decide what you think that 50 50 odds
should be but you can use my formula to
plug in whatever you want and get the
answer and I use 50 50. so and but when
in that first pile uh with the first two
parts of the the the the the the
bathroom talks about it seems like
connected to that is the question we've
been talking about which is the number
of times at bat you get which is the
number of intelligent civilizations that
are out there that can
uh build such simulations that's it
seems like very closely connected
because if we're the only ones that are
here and can build such things that
changes things yeah yeah I mean this
yeah the signatures has all sorts of
implications like that
um I've always loved showing PowerPoints
about a really interesting contradiction
apparently with the simulation
hypothesis that I speak about a little
bit in the paper
but he showed that um or pointed out
that in this hierarchy of realities
which then developed their own AIS
within the realities and then they just
or really ancestor simulations I should
say rather than AI they develop their
own capability to simulate realities you
get this hierarchy until eventually
there'll be a bottom layer
um which I often call the sewer of
reality it's like the worst layer where
it's the most pixelated it could
possibly be right so because each layer
is necessarily going to have less
computational power than the layer above
it because not only are you stimulating
that entire planet but also some of
that's being used for the computers
themselves so those are simulated and so
that base reality also about the suit of
reality is a is a is a reality where
they are simply unable to produce
ancestor simulations because the
Fidelity the simulation is not
sufficient and so from their point of
view it might not be obvious that the
universe is pixelated but they would
just never be able to manifest that
capability what if they're constantly
simulating
uh because it in order to uh appreciate
the limits of the Fidelity you have to
have an observer what if they're always
simulating a dumber and dumber Observer
yeah what if the sewer has very dumb
observers they can't like scientists
that are the dumbest possible scientists
so like it's it's very pixelated but the
scientists are too dumb to even see the
pixelations right like that that's like
built into the universe always has to be
a limitation on the cognitive
capabilities of the complex systems that
are within it yeah so that fear of
reality they would still presumably be
able to have a very impressive
computational capabilities they'll
probably be able to simulate Galactic
formation or this kind of impressive
stuff but they would be just short of
the ability to however you define it
credit truly sentient conscious
experience in a computer that would just
be just beyond their capabilities and so
uh Carol points out that if you add up
all the you know you count up how many
realities there should be
probabilistically if this is true over
here the simulation uh hypothesis or
scenario then you're most likely to find
yourself in the sewer because this far
more of them than there are of any of
the higher levels so and so that sort of
sets up a contradiction because then you
live in a reality which is inherently
incapable of ever producing ancestor
simulations
but the premise of the entire argument
is that ancestor simulations are
possible so there's there's a
contradiction
does that old quote we're all living in
the sewer but some of us are looking up
at the stars
this is maybe more true than we think
uh but to me so there's of course
physics and computational uh fascinating
questions here but to me there's a
practical psychological question which
is you know how do you create a virtual
reality world
that is as compelling and not
necessarily even as realistic but
almost as realistic
but as compelling or more compelling
Than Physical reality
because something tells me it's not it's
not very difficult in the in the in um
full history of human civilization that
that is an interesting
kind of simulation to me because that
feels like it's doable in the next 100
years creating a world where we're all
prefer to live in the digital world and
not like a visit but like it's like
your scene is insane no like you're
required it's unsafe to live outside of
the virtual world and uh it's
interesting to me from an engineering
perspective how to build that because
I'm somebody that sort of loves video
games and it seems like you can create
incredible worlds there and stay there
and uh that's a it's a different
question than creating a ultra high
resolution High Fidelity simulation of
physics but if that world inside a video
game is
as consistent as the physics of our
reality that you can have your own
scientists in that world that trying to
understand that physics World it might
look different
that eventually forget you know give it
give it long enough they might forget
about their origins of being once
biological and assume this is their only
reality especially if you're now born
you know uh well certainly if you're
born but even if
you're eight years old or something when
you first started wearing the headset
yeah or you could have a memory wipe
when you go in I mean it it also kind of
maybe speaks to this issue of like
neuralink and how do we keep up with AI
in our world
if you want to augment your intelligence
um perhaps one way of competing and the
one of your impetuses for going into
this digital reality would be to be
competitive intellectually with
um artificial intelligences that you
could trivially augment your reality if
your brain was itself artificial but
I mean one one steps is my voice had
about that is is whether it's from a
first tough question but how much is
that really you if you do a mind upload
is this just a duplicate of your
memories that thinks it's you versus
truly a transference of your contrast
stream into that reality and I think
when you uh
it's almost like the teleportation
device in Star Trek
um but with teleportation quantum
teleportation you can kind of rigorously
show that
um that you know all as long as all of
the
quantum numbers are exactly duplicated
as you transfer over it truly is from
the universe's perspective in every way
indistinguishable from what was there
before it really is in principle of you
and all the sense of being you versus
creating a duplicate clone and uploading
memories to that human body or a
computer that would
surely be a a discontinuation of that
conscious experience by virtue of the
fact you've multiplied it and so I
I would be hesitant about uploading for
that reason I would see it mostly as my
own killing myself and having some
um
AI duplicate of me that persists in this
world but is not truly my experience
typical
20th century human with an attachment to
this particular singular instantiation
of brain and body
how silly humans used to be used to have
rotary phones and
um
and and other silly things